[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen es ist nichts an
dass wir uns gewöhnen können Russland
überzieht die Ukraine mit einer neuen
Angriffswelle die schwerste seit Wochen
auf den Osten den Westen des Landes in
Kiew wurden die Bewohner durch
Explosionen aus dem Schlaf gerissen die
Ukraine meldet sechs Tote mindestens und
bei der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde klingen sie zunehmend
verzweifelt weil Europas größtes
Kernkraftwerk in saporicia durch die
Angriffe zwischendurch wieder vom
Stromnetz abgeschnitten wurde wie kann
es sein dass wir so etwas geschehen
lassen fragt der Direktor der
internationalen Beobachter es könne so
nicht weitergehen Henna Hebestreit
berichtet aus saporicia
es ist die brutale Erinnerung daran dass
überall in der Ukraine russische Raketen
einschlagen können fünf Tote und viele
Verletzte sind allein im vermeintlich
sichereren Westen der Ukraine die Bilanz
dieser schlimmsten Attacke Moskau seit
langem
ich habe zum ersten mal solch eine
Tragödie erlebt das ist schrecklich wir
fehlen die Worte Russland ist teuflisch
das ist eine schreckliche Plage
über 80 Geschosse hat Moskaus Militär
nach eigenen Worten abgefeuert auf
strategische Ziele diese Bilder zeigen
dass auf die Zivilbevölkerung dabei
keine Rücksicht genommen wird
in saporicia haben sie sich am Mittag
von Opfern des letzten Angriffs
verabschiedet bei dem 15 Menschen
starben in der Stadt versuchen Sie eine
noch viel größere Gefahr zu verdrängen
das nahegelegene Atomkraftwerk trennen
nach russischen Beschuss nur noch zehn
Notstromaggregate von einem nuklearen
Katastrophe
das ist Europas größtes Atomkraftwerk
und es hängt zum sechsten Mal von
Notstrom Dieseln ab was wollen wir denn
tun
schon lange schaut die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft nur zu wie sie von
Russland mit dem Kraftwerk erpresst wird
so wurden Stau damit es nie pro geöffnet
was die Versorgung des Atomkraftwerks
mit Kühlwasser bedroht
im Januar hat Russland Wasser abgelassen
um die besetzte Krim damit zu versorgen
als Resultat sank der Wasserstand des
nipron neben dem Atomkraftwerk
saporisier um 2 m
weniger Wasser bedeutet auch eine
geringere Kühlung der Anlage
außerdem stellt die Anwesenheit
russischer Truppen auf dem
Kraftwerksgelände immer noch eine Gefahr
für die Anlage und die ganze Region da
die Notfallzentrale des Kraftwerks ist
nicht mehr im Betrieb denn dort befinden
sich russische Soldaten und haben ihre
Fahrzeuge und Munition gelagert die
außerhalb gelegene not Zentrale in
saporicia hat keine Verbindung mehr zu
dem Kraftwerk und deshalb bekommen wir
keine Informationen wenn es zu
Störfällen kommt
inzwischen konnten die Techniker die
Stromversorgung wenigstens zum Teil
wieder herstellen
saporisia ist heute noch einmal
davongekommen
der Chef der Atomenergiebehörde sagt es
ist jedes Mal wie ein Würfelspiel und
irgendwann wird unser Glück uns
verlassen Henna Hebestreit in der
Ukraine genannt Hannah wie viel Glück
haben wir denn heute gehabt dass nichts
schlimmeres passiert ist mit dem
Atomkraftwerk
ich glaube das hat mit Glück wenig zu
tun das ist eine gezielte
Eskalation immer einen kleinen Schritt
weiter
seitens der Russen die wissen natürlich
auch wenn das Ding in die Luft fliegt
dann beschränkt sich die Verstrahlung
nicht nur auf die Ukraine oder auf Teile
Europas dann besteht die Gefahr dass
natürlich auch große Teile Russlands
verstrahlt werden dazu wird man das
sicherlich nicht kommen lassen der
Treibstoffvorrat dieser
Dieselgeneratoren die den die die
Stromversorgung sichergestellt haben es
geht um den Betrieb der Anlage die
liefert schon lange keinen Strom mehr
aber es geht um den Betrieb der Anlage
der hält mehrere Tage vielleicht zwei
Wochen vor und vielleicht verlässt man
sich darauf dass die ukrainischen
Ingenieure sehr schnell in der Lage sind
die Schäden zu reparieren sowas ja heute
auch dann reden wir ändern auch über die
aktuelle Angriffswelle so eine
Bandbreite von geschossen habe es noch
nie gegeben sagt der Sprecher der
Luftwaffe in der Ukraine was hat denn
das jetzt mit der Wärme und
Stromversorgung angerichtet im Land
die Stromversorgung ist schon in der
Nacht abgeschaltet worden als der erste
Alarm los ging das hat man zur
Sicherheit gemacht damit nicht durch
raketeneinschläge dann unkontrollierte
Abschaltungen passieren hier hat es
heute morgen auch mächtig gerumst aber
es ist offenbar nicht viel passiert hier
in niebro der Strom war sehr schnell
wieder da aber wir hören aus Kiew das
eine ein Anlage zur Wärmeversorgung
getroffen wurde da ist sehr viel Wärme
ausgefallen in Rakel gibt es Probleme
mit dem Strom in Odessa gibt es Probleme
mit dem Strom
das wird jetzt ein paar Tage dauern bis
die ukrainischen Ingenieure das wieder
gerichtet haben und dann kann man
wahrscheinlich die Uhr danach stellen
das ist eine Frage von Wochen ist wenn
Russland die nächste Attacke startet
vielen Dank
und dann müssen wir auf ein anderes
russisches Nachbarland gucken in dem
viele befürchten dass ich Geschichte
wiederholen könnte
Georgien liegt im Kaukasus an der
Schnittstelle zwischen Europa und Asien
das Land sagt sich 1991 von der
Sowjetunion los erklärt sich für
unabhängig und hatte danach bereits
einen Krieg mit Russland das war 2008 es
geht um die abtrünnigen Regionen
südostizien und Asien auch der Westen
wird damals kalt erwischt das Russland
tatsächlich Panzer auffährt und der
Konflikt schwillt bis heute denn seitdem
kontrolliert Moskau die beiden
international nicht anerkannten
Republiken
und jetzt eskaliert die Lage in Georgien
neu es gibt tagelange Straßen Proteste
gegen ein neues Mediengesetz der
Regierung es gibt auch Gewalt die
Menschen die da protestieren sind für
einen Beitritt ihres Landes zu EU und
NATO sie sehen in dem Gesetz einen
Versuch nach russischen Vorbild
kritische Berichte zu unterbinden die
Regierung lenkt jetzt erstmal ein zieht
das Gesetz zurück die Proteste sollen
aber weitergehen es geht längst um mehr
um die Frage ob sich Georgien weiter
Europa zuwendet oder ein neuer Kurs
beginnt auf den Straßen von tief ist
jedenfalls schwenken Sie blaue Fahnen
mit goldenen Sternen Sebastian eben
berichtet
es ist der dritte Tag in Folge an dem
sich wieder tausende Georgier der
Polizei entgegenstellen obwohl sie mit
Wasserwerfern Tränengas und
Schlagstöcken rechnen müssen
[Applaus]
wir werden die Proteste fortsetzen bis
die Mitglieder des Parlaments mit ihren
eigenen Händen den Knopf drücken und
dieses Gesetz für nichtig erklären
und so versammelt sich auch zur Stunde
wieder die pro-europäische Jugend vor
dem georgischen Parlament den Tiflis und
protestiert gegen den Einfluss Russlands
im Zentrum der Kritik steht die
Regierungspartei die heute auf den Druck
der Straße reagieren musste und
beteuerte das umstrittene
Gesetzesvorhaben nicht umzusetzen
wir haben uns entschieden Nein zu diesem
Gesetz zu sagen und es abzulegen
es ist ein Sieg der Demonstranten nach
dramatischen Tagen in Tiflis Barrikaden
brannten die Polizei setzte Wasserwerfer
ein über 60 Menschen wurden festgenommen
seit Monaten wächst die Unzufriedenheit
mit Premierminister
irakwili der sich heute nicht äußerte
ihm wird eine zu große Nähe zum Moskau
vorgeworfen die georgische Präsidentin
ist für einen EU-Beitritt Georgiens und
spricht aus New York in die Heimat
an eurer Seite
ihr repräsentiert das freie Georgien
Georgien sieht seine Zukunft in Europa
und wir werden es niemanden erlauben uns
diese Zukunft wegzunehmen
der Kampf um den richtigen Kurs
Georgiens mündete vor zwei Tagen gar in
Tumulten im Sitzungssaal des Parlaments
das Vorhaben erinnert viele an Russland
wo ebenfalls ein ausländisches
agentengesetz dafür genutzt wurde Presse
und Meinungsfreiheit immer weiter
auszuüben
Putin verliert in der Ukraine und der
versucht das auszugleichen indem er in
Nachbarländern tätig wird
georgien ist ein leichtes Ziel weil es
nicht geschützt ist es ist kleiner und
schwächer und Russland hat hier in den
besetzten Gebieten militärische
Infrastruktur
am Abend wird bekannt dass alle
festgenommenen Demonstranten frei kommen
in Tiflis bleibt es heute friedlich nach
der Wut der letzten Tage sind sie hier
hauptsächlich stolz denn heute so sagen
sie hätten sie es geschafft dem langen
Arm Moskaus zu trotzen zumindest vorerst
[Musik]
und dann in einer Welt in der gerade so
viel aus den Fugen gerät heftige
Proteste auch in Israel aus Sorge um
nichts weniger als die Demokratie
zwischen HIV und erst dort demonstrieren
mittlerweile Eltern und Kinder auf dem
Weg zur Schule am meerreservisten und
Veteranen errichten Straßenblockaden
zwei frühere marine-chefs sind mit
Segelbooten und Kajaks auf dem Wasser
mit dabei und selbst ehemalige
Geheimdienstler von shindebett und
Mossad kommen aus der Deckung und warnen
in eindringlichen Worten die Regierung
mit einem Yahoo und ihre Justizreform
bringen das Land an den Abgrund per
Fernsehansprache heute abend meldet sich
Staatspräsident Isaak Herzog was gerade
in Israel geschieht sagt er ist ein
Desaster aus tel avivalpott
sie nennen es nationalen Tag der Störung
wie schon letzte Woche zogen auch heute
wieder zehntausende besorgte Bürgerinnen
und Bürger mit Nationalflaggen gegen die
sogenannte Justizreform auf die Straße
und blockierten Verkehrsadern in Sorge
um den Fortbestand der Gewaltenteilung
der Demokratie schlechthin
[Musik]
wir sind an einem Punkt wenn wir nicht
auf die Straße gehen dann nehmen sie uns
alle Rechte Weg die Frage ist nicht mehr
ob oder wann es geschieht gerade
[Applaus]
ich bin 27 und ich möchte dass meine
Kinder in einem demokratischen
Rechtsstaat aufwachsen ich will die ja
Zukunft haben ohne Demokratie keine
Zukunft
sie wollen ein Regime der Mehrheit und
die Rechte der Minderheiten abschaffen
weder die Palästinenser noch die Frauen
oder schwulen werden dann Rechte haben
es wird ein Land in dem nur noch die
Mehrheit alles entscheidet
Blockaden und erhebliche Störungen auch
am Flughafen in Tel Aviv wo der Mann der
diesen Proteststurm ausgelöst hat
Regierungschef netanjau sich vor seiner
Abreise nach Rom noch mit dem
amerikanischen Verteidigungsminister
Austin traf während der us-gast die
jüngste siedlergewalt gegen
Palästinenser scharf verurteilte und
hervorhub das zur israelischen
Demokratie eine unabhängige Justiz
gehöre sieht netanjau Demokratie und
recht Staat nicht den Gefahr die
Mehrheit habe nur mal entschieden
diese Demonstranten wollen eine
demokratisch gewählte Regierung stürzen
sie wollen Neuwahlen das werden wir
nicht zulassen wir werden alles
unternehmen um die Störungen im Alltag
durch diese Demonstrationen so gering
wie möglich zu halten aber klar ist
unsere Entscheidungen sind Ausdruck
einer gewählten Mehrheit in diesem Staat
warum
das Land ist tief gespalten zwischen
liberalen und linken in der Opposition
rechtsnationalen radikalen Zionisten und
ultra religiösen in der Regierung die
nutzen jetzt die Gunst der Stunde glaubt
die konservative Juristin Einhorn das
Oberste Gericht reflektieren nicht mehr
die gesellschaftliche Realität
viele von uns wollten eine solche Reform
schon seit 20 Jahren aber wir hatten
einfach nie die 61 Stimmen Mehrheit im
Parlament Wortes
wenn die Richter sich selbst ernennen
dann haben sie ein Gericht in dem zehn
von elfrechtern die gleiche Meinung
vertreten und die kann ganz anders sein
als die Bedürfnisse der Bürger
im Klartext der Oberste Gerichtshof ist
netanjau und seiner Koalition einfach zu
links liberal das soll sich jetzt ändern
mitten in die aufgeladene Stimmung
fielen am Abend in Tel Aviv wieder
Schüsse israelische Medien berichten von
einem mutmaßlich palästinensischen
Attentäter drei Menschen wurden verletzt
die Polizei erschossen den Angreifer
der Ex Ministerpräsident und jetzige
Oppositionsführer ja ihre Lapid warnt
sollte die Justizreform umgesetzt werden
könnte es in Israel nie wieder Wahlen
geben Zitat es wird hier keine
Demokratie mehr geben Zitat Ende es gibt
Israelis die tragen sich mit dem
Gedanken auszuwandern schweren Herzens
Hannah du machst jetzt den ersten
Nachrichtenblock bei uns in der Sendung
ganz genau Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
will offenbar die für nächsten Mittwoch
geplante Vorstellung des Haushalts 2024
im Kabinett verschieben das berichtet
unter anderem die Deutsche Presseagentur
die Regierung werde noch einmal
gemeinsam über finanzielle Realitäten
sprechen müssen so lindbar einen neuen
Zeitpunkt nenne er ausdrücklich nicht
seine Ministerkollegen hätten
Zusatzwünsche von 70 Milliarden Euro
angemeldet für die Lindner im Haushalt
keinen Spielraum sehe
seit Monaten blockiert die Türkei den
NATO Beitritt von Schweden und Finnland
nun haben sich die drei Länder nach
wochenlanger Pause erstmals wieder zu
Gesprächen getroffen alleine das wird
als wichtiges Signal gewertet auch wenn
die Beratungen heute keinen Durchbruch
brachten die Türkei fordert von Schweden
ein härteres Vorgehen gegen Extremisten
die schwedische Regierung kündigte heute
unterdessen ein härteres Anti
terrorgesetz an nachdem es künftig
strafbar sein soll sich an einer
Terrororganisation zu beteiligen
italien will künftig mit härteren
Strafen gegen Schlepper im Mittelmeer
Vorgehen Regierungschef in Meloni
erklärte nach einem Beschluss des
Ministerrats Schleusern und
hinterbännern würden in Zukunft
Gefängnisstrafen von bis zu 30 Jahren
drohen wenn es zu Unfällen mit toten
komme damit reagierte die ultra-rechte
Regierung auf das verheerende
bootsunglückende Februar bei dem
mindestens 72 Menschen starben
trotz der massiven Proteste und Streiks
gegen die geplante Rentenreform in
Frankreich hat der französische Senat in
der Nacht einer Erhöhung des
Renteneintrittsalters zugestimmt damit
hat das Vorhaben des französischen
Präsidenten macron eine wichtige Hürde
genommen besiegelt ist es damit
allerdings noch nicht denn auch die
Nationalversammlung muss den Pläne noch
zustimmen auch heute gab es wieder
Proteste gegen die Reform etwa in Paris
diese sieht unter anderem eine Anhebung
des Rentenalters von 62 auf 64 Jahre vor
in Frankfurt hat heute das fünfte und
vorerst letzte Treffen des katholischen
reformprojekts synodaler Weg begonnen am
Abend beschloss die Versammlung aus
Klerikern und Leiden mehrheitlich unter
anderem den Papst zur Prüfung des
Pflicht Zölibats aufzufordern noch bis
Samstag debattieren über 200 Delegierte
überreformvorschläge etwa zur Rolle von
Frauen und zur Homosexualität der
Vatikan steht dem Projekt kritisch
gegenüber
jetzt geht es um ein Großprojekt das uns
wirklich alle betrifft Ärztinnen und
Ärzte führen die Akten über ihre
Patienten ja bislang meist Hand
geschrieben oder auf dem eigenen
Computer dazu kommen dann
Behandlungsunterlagen aus Krankenhäusern
gern per Fax im Ausland schütteln Sie
den Kopf über so viel digitale Uhrzeit
und tatsächlich gibt es auch bei uns
schon länger die elektronische
Patientenakte die alles zusammenführen
soll im Notfall helfen und der Forschung
Daten liefern die Grundlagen damals
gelegt von Gesundheitsministerin Ulla
Schmidt die älteren erinnern sich
genutzt hat sie bislang praktisch
niemand das soll sich ändern und zwar
schnell sagt jetzt der aktuelle Minister
auch wenn es noch viele viele offene
Fragen gibt Christiane hübscher
Röntgenbilder Arztbriefe Testergebnisse
eine riesige Zettelwirtschaft sammelt
sich da an in einem einzigen
patientenleben all diese Daten
stattdessen gebündelt in einer App der
Krankenkassen das ist die Idee der
elektronischen Patientenakte kurz EPA
mit der EPA erhalten wir nun endlich
einen Platz wo alle persönlichen
Gesundheitsdaten ein Zuhause finden der
Vorteil jeder Arzt kann sofort die
medizinische Vorgeschichte eines
Patienten sehen doch weniger als ein
Prozent der Versicherten nutzt bisher
die Ehepaar der
Bundesgesundheitsminister will dieses 20
Jahre alte politische Projekt endlich
zum Fliegen bringen mit mehr Druck das
Ziel 80% der gesetzlich Versicherten
sollen bis 2025 eine elektronische
Patientenakte haben ich glaube dass man
das was wir heute vorstellen nicht
unterschätzen sollte werden wir hier
einen Durchbruch schaffen dann wird das
auch die praktische Medizin verändern
Patient plötzlich alle Befunde eines
Patienten zu jedem Zeitpunkt dass sie
sind da Lauterbach hat dabei nicht vor
wirklich fragen zu lassen ob jemand eine
elektronische Patientenakte wünscht wer
nicht aktiv widerspricht stimmt
automatisch zu so ist es geplant
Patienten Schützer kritisieren niemandem
dürfe die Kontrolle über seine
persönlichen Gesundheitsdaten entzogen
werden Herr Lauterbach
sowohl bei den patientenrechten als auch
beim Datenschutz gilt wer schweigt
stimmt nicht zu auf viele Fragen hat
Lauterbach heute noch gar keine Antwort
seine Gesetzesinitiative wirkt recht
unfertig wo und wie widerspreche ich
denn muss ich mich dafür irgendwo
einloggen kriegt einen Brief von meiner
Krankenkasse wo ich was ankreuze werde
ich das beim Arzt gefragt wie soll das
Laufen
ja das also Widerspruchsverfahren das
werden wir noch entwickeln und das also
vorgestellt wenn wir das Gesetz
demnächst also ihnen präsentieren sicher
wie im Tresor sein die medizinischen
Daten verspricht die EPA App Experten
aber sehen drastische
informationssicherheitsmenge man stellt
sich noch mal vor Daten kommen aus der
falschen Quelle in so eine Akte und
darauf wird dann befundet oder daraufhin
werden dann bestimmt Entscheidungen und
Diagnose Entscheidungen getroffen das
sind alles Dinge die zusätzlich zu
dieser hohen Vertraulichkeit diese
medizinischen Daten noch ins Feld
geführt werden müssen und die diskutiert
werden müssen dieser Stuttgarter
Hausarzt sagt klar digitale Vernetzung
von Praxen klingt gut doch er sieht vor
allem noch mehr Dokumentationsarbeit auf
sich zukommen die zudem schlecht bezahlt
wird das Befüllen einer Patienten
elektronischen Patientenakte wird mit 10
€ vergütet und die weitere Pflege die
sehr aufwendig ist umso besser die Daten
umso besser ist die elektronische
Patientenakte wird mit 1,67 € vergütet
können sich vorstellen wie groß da die
Motivation ist vom Defätismus der Ärzte
hat Karl Lauterbach heute gesprochen
aber wegen all des Widerstands die
Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens
aufgeben keine Option so der Minister
einer der geklagt hat gegen die Sammlung
von Gesundheitsdaten ist nachher im
heute journal Update bei Nazan gödemia
viel Zeit zu verlieren gibt es
tatsächlich nicht angesichtszahl der
Baustellen in Berlin gehen CDU und SPD
ab heute in Koalitionsverhandlungen am
Tisch sitzen ein Wahlgewinner Kai Wegner
CDU und eine wahlverliererin Franziska
Giffey SPD sollten die Verhandlungen ein
Ergebnis bringen wäre sie zwar ihr
bisheriges Amt als Regierende
Bürgermeisterin los könnte aber als
Senatorin unter einem Regierenden Wegner
weitermachen allerdings ist das alles
andere als sicher und zwar
interessanterweise wegen giffeis eigenen
Leuten die da nicht alle mitziehen
wollen mehr von Markus groß und Stefan
Merseburger
er hat es eilig und kennt sein Ziel
Bürgermeister werden endlich nach 21
Jahren wieder ein Christdemokrat Kai
Wegner Clara weil Sieger
sind die dicken roten Ordner der Weg ins
Rathaus führt über uns Bürgermeisterin
Ihren Traumjob opfert Franziska Giffey
lautet ihre Erzählung für nichts
Geringeres als das Wohl der Stadt
wir wollen das Beste für Berlin
erreichen gemeinsam in einem
konstruktiven Prozess in einem
sachlichen pragmatischen
lösungsorientierten Diskurs ich bin mir
ganz sicher dass wir am Ende des Monats
März dann ein gutes Ergebnis für Berlin
präsentieren werden darum geht es am
Ende des Tages und heute fangen wir
damit richtig motiviert an ins Rote
Rathaus sollen Wegner sogenannte
Schnittmengen führen die haben CDU und
SPD bei den Themen innere Sicherheit
eine besser funktionierenden Verwaltung
und beim Neubau zur Bekämpfung der
Wohnungsnot die CDU will darüber hinaus
den Ausbau der Stadtautobahn A100 und
eine Randbebauung des Tempelhofer Feldes
dagegen gibt es wieder stand in der SPD
am Ende bin ich sehr sicher
dass wenn ein gut ausgehandelter Vertrag
auf dem Tisch liegt wenn wichtige Themen
die der Sozialdemokratie wichtig sind
hier auch mit drin sind dann wird es auf
jeden Fall auch eine Auseinandersetzung
anhand der Themen geben und dann denke
ich schon dass wir die Mehrheit der
Mitglieder auch überzeugen können die
Mitglieder so hat es die Parteiführung
entschieden sollen die schwarz-rote
Koalition absegnen nicht die
Parteifunktionäre
wir finden auch nicht okay dass die
Partei nicht im Rahmen eines Parteitags
darüber diskutieren kann und am Ende
auch noch mal vielleicht das mit dieser
Votum im bestätigen kann sondern dass
das rein durch das mit dieser Votum
jetzt abgefrühstückt wird der Parteitag
könnte schwarz rot wohlmöglich platzen
lassen in der Partei wie hier an der
Basis in Mitte rumor des heftig
zu viele bekommen haben das ist alles
andere als ein Selbstläufer und auch
Leute die ich sag mal nicht dezidiert im
linken Lager sind sagen diesmal kann ich
an der Stelle da wirklich nicht ja sagen
ich empfinde die Berliner SPD meinen
Landesverband als ein eher linken
Landesverband und deshalb finde ich
eigentlich dass man mehr SPD-Politik mit
grünen und mit der Linkspartei umsetzen
kann doch gifhei hat Grünen und Linken
die Tür definitiv zugeschlagen mit
welchem Motiv es ist insgesamt mit Blick
auf die nächste Wahl die ihr schon in
knapp drei Jahren stattfindet insgesamt
die bessere Ausgangsposition jetzt zu
sagen wir haben verstanden wir können
nicht einfach so weitermachen aber wir
stehen durchaus dann auch wieder bereit
für den ersten Platz es ist ein
Machtpoker das Kalkül ein kleines Opfer
bringen um am Ende doch wieder im Roten
Rathaus zu landen
so und jetzt geht es um die Post mit
Diana
die Mitglieder bei der Deutschen Post
ist nämlich eindeutig fast 86 Prozent
sprachen sich in einer urab
Stimmen für einen unbefristeten Streik
aus das bedeutet schon bald könnten
viele Päckchen und Briefe wieder liegen
bleiben allerdings Frank Bethmann erst
soll noch mal verhandelt werden heißt
dass der Streik könnte doch noch
abgewendet werden ja das ist die
Hoffnung auch wenn beide Seiten sagen
sie würden an ihren Positionen
festhalten ist es doch zumindest ein
gutes Zeichen von außen betrachtet ist
man letztendlich auch gar nicht mehr so
weit voneinander entfernt wer die
fordert für die Beschäftigten 15% mehr
Gehalt Laufzeit ein Jahr die Post sagt
das ist wirtschaftlich nicht vertretbar
und bietet in zwei Stufen mal 20 24 eine
Tariferhöhung an die entspricht einem
Entgelt Plus von durchschnittlich 11,5%
sagt das Management separat hierzu
sollen die Beschäftigten schrittweise
3000 € netto bekommen eine
Inflationsausgleich Prämie ab morgen
wird weiter verhandelt ein unbefristeter
Streit kann jetzt aber jederzeit
ausgerufen werden das dürfte werden dies
Position stärken
gleichzeitig hat die Post heute
Rekordzahlen vermeldet doch auch hier
gibt es ein großes aber oder ja 8,4
Milliarden Euro Betriebsgewinn vor
Zinsen und Steuern kann sich sehen
lassen das Frachtgeschäft boomte auch
der Paketversand im Ausland und die
Expresszustellung das eigentliche
stammengeschäft aber der Brief und
Paketversand im Inland das lief nicht so
gut ordentliches Geld verdient
Deutschlands führender Logistikkonzern
vor allem im Ausland und so stellt sich
die Post auch auf den Standpunkt zu hohe
Lohnforderungen würden das
Deutschland-Geschäft eben unprofitabel
machen und zum Abbau von Jobs führen
vielen Dank für deine Einschätzung
Kohle hat für die Stromproduktion in
Deutschland an Bedeutung gewonnen laut
dem Statistischen Bundesamt stammte im
vergangenen Jahr ein Drittel des
erzeugten Stroms aus Kohlekraftwerken
8,4% mehr als im Vorjahr grund dafür war
ein starker Rückgang der Stromproduktion
aus Erdgas und Atomkraft
zweitwichtigste Energiequelle war die
Windkraft mit einem Anteil von 9,4%
. zum Fußball dort trafen im
Achtelfinale der Europa League am Abend
Union Berlin und unions aufeinander
entstand drei zu drei und außerdem
spielte Bayer Leverkusen gegen swarosch
Budapest und siegte mit 2:0
zum Auftakt des Biathlon Weltcups im
schwedischen Östersund sicherten sich
die deutschen Biathletinnen und
Biathleten gleich zwei Podestplätze
Benedikt doll gewann souverän das Einzel
der Männer und schoss fünf Mal
fehlerfrei auf Rang 2 und 3 landeten
Italien und Norwegen und auch für Denise
hermannweg gab es allen Grund zum Jubeln
sie wurde im Einzel dritte hinter den
Italienerinnen Dorothea wiera und Lisa
die letzte Überlebende der
Widerstandsgruppe weiße Rose traute
Lafrenz ist tot sie starb am Montag im
Alter von 103 Jahren in den USA in
München lernte Lafrenz als
Medizinstudentin die Geschwister Scholl
kennen und beteiligte sich ab 1942 an
Flugblattaktionen gegen die
Nationalsozialisten nach ihrer Befreiung
aus der NS Gefangenschaft wanderte sie
in die USA aus
so hier bei uns im ZDF geht's jetzt
weiter mit der Kollegin Maybrit Illner
ihr Thema Spielball der Weltmächte und
ihre Frage kommt die Ukraine Hilfe zu
spät das jetzt gleich nach uns und wir
hier alle im heute journal auch die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras danken herzlich für Ihr
Interesse und gegen 0:30 Uhr gibt's
später unser heute journal Update mit
Nazan gehört tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein Sturmtief
nähert sich von Westen her und wird uns
bis Samstag dann ostwärts überqueren
morgen ist aber einiges los mit Schnee
und teils auch Sturmböen bis ins
Flachland so sieht's in der Nacht aus da
schneit es nach Norden hin sonst kommt
von Südwesten neuer Regen auf die
Temperaturen gehen zurück bis auf 9 bis
10 Grad im Südwesten Deutschland sonst
nach Norden bis minus zwei Grad
frostigkeit die Luftmassengrenze ist
hier gut zu erkennen einmal quer über
Deutschland ja morgen dann viel los im
Süden erst einmal Aufzug vom neuen Regen
dazu sturmböden bis ins Flachland das
breitet sich dann auch Richtung Südosten
aus sonst dann im Norden Schneefall
davon ebenfalls dann zum Abend und zum
Nachmittag im Westen und im Nordwesten
und dort dann auch Sturmböen Wissens
Flachland bei höchsten Temperaturen bis
14 Grad Richtung Südosten häufig Werte
um 12 Grad nach Süden nach Norden in
deutlich kälter bei zwei bis drei Grad
sind es hier schon an den Farben hier
ist die Luftmassengrenze weiterhin quer
über Deutschland vorhanden die nächsten
Tage bleiben ungemütlich am Samstag am
ehesten noch von Westen etwas
Sonnenschein sonst Regen und Schnee bei
1 bis 7 Grad am Sonntag verbreitet Regen
und schneewitha bei 4 bis 13 Grad Mutter
kommt neuer Sturm auf und Werte bis 18
Grad ein schöner Abend